Esto se debe principalmente a tres
factores el primero es la disminución de
la capacidad de las autoridades para
identificar casos y esto estamos
hablando dentro de la situación de
pandemia que se vivió Por otra parte el
desplazamiento de la explotación
especialmente la explotación sexual de
lugares públicos o abiertos a lugares
privados Como por ejemplo
hoteles y apartamentos Esto hace que se
dificulte mucho más la actividad de las
autoridades para identificar casos de
trata y En tercer lugar estamos hablando
de la disminución de las actividades de
los tratantes correspondientes a los
periodos de aislamiento obligatorio que
se vivieron durante la pandemia